[Applaudissements]
morin décembre j'habite paris j'habite
en suisse d'habitude j'aime pas venir à
paris mais pour une minute ça va non
j'ai pas ici tout va trop vite ça me
fatigue
je crois que si je suis venu c'est
uniquement parce que paris est en zone
rouge donc quand je rentre j'ai une
semaine de quarantaine pour me reposer
une minute de travail pour une semaine
de glandes j'ai l'impression d'être
influenceurs ou pénélope fillon
je fais des blagues sur pénélope fillon
bassu nostalgiques de 2010 est ce que
notre problème principal c'est et
pénélope fillon
je suis venu parce que ça ne tenait à
coeur de voir des français respecter un
horaire c'est la première fois que
bassin qui a lancé un génie franchement
ken hill a fait bref c'est comme une
série exode plus court jenny fait 60
c'est comme un gars avec des passages
plus court jenny près j'ai vu mon cachet
génie bonjour une minute je vais me
reposer
merci
[Applaudissements]